نعم خالد لكن قبل الدخول في
التطورات في باخمت لابد من الاشاره الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه استانفت قصفها لمدينه
دانيت خلال اليومين الماضيين كانت هناك
عمليات عسكريه او ضربات بصواريخ هايمرز
الامريكيه كما انها استخدمت صواريخ تشيكيه
الصنع من طراز فامبير يعني صواريخ جراد
بولنديه الصنع سقطت في مناطق مختلفه خلف
القصف عشره
ضحايا واعداد من الاصابات وتزامن هذا
القصف مع تصريحات الرئيس الروسي بلادي
مربوطن باهميه ابعاد القوات الاوكرانيه عن
مناطق المدنيين في دانيت وخاصه حديث عن ان
مهمه جيش الروسي هي ايقاف الحرب في او
ايقاف اطلاق النار في دمباس
المعارك طبعا مستمره على جميع المحاور في
مختلفه واهمها مدينه باخمت
تقدمت القوات
الروسيه وقوات فاجنر تحديدا في عمق
المدينه بعد سيطرتها على المباني الاداريه
في قلب المدينه
وتخوض معارك شرسه بالفعل في مناطق السكك
الحديديه كما ان هناك مقاومه شرسه من
الاجانب الاوكراني في المحور الشمالي حول
بلده
اريخاباسيلوكا ماذا لا تقاوم القوات
الاوكرانيه في المحور الشمالي والغربي
وتمنع تقدم قوات فارنر كما ان الامدادات
ما زالت تصل عن طريق مدينه شاسوفيار التي
عجزت عن اقتحامها حتى الان قوات فاجنر
هناك بلده عصيت على القوات الخاصه الروسيه
وهي بلده بلدا في المحور الغربي لو
استطاعت القوات الروسيه او قوات فاجنر
الخاصه من الازدتحام هذه المدينه والسيطره
عليها لكانت قد اكملت الطوق لكن الامدادات
ما زالت تصل بسبب صمود القوات الاوكرانيه
في ذلك المحور الاله العسكريه الثقيله
تعمل في الجانبين الجنوبي والشرقي حيث
القصف العنيف من قبل من المدافع ومن
راجمات الصواريخ كما ان المقاتلات الروسيه
ما زالت تحلق في هذان الجانبين بالفعل
هناك اكثر من خمسه خمسه عشر الف مقاتل
اوكرانيا حسب الاحصاءات داخل مدينه باقمت
كما ان هناك اعداد كبيره مدينه باخمت خالد
هي رمزيه للطرفين الطرف الروسي والطرف
الاوكراني حوالي ثمانيه اشهر ولم يستطع
الجيش الروسي او قوات فاجنر السيطره عليها
والطرفين معنيين اما اذا كان الروسي اذا
سيطر عليها فهذا يعني انه سيتقدم الى
المدن الكبرى خلفها واذا صمد الجيش
الاوكراني فهذا يعني انه قادر على الصمود
في هذه الحرب بشكل عام هناك محاور كثيره
وايضا اوغلادار معارك داريه في كل هذه
المناطق لا تتوقف المعارك ولا تقدم على
الارض فعلي يعني
مسجل للجيش الروسي هناك محاولات للاقتحام
لكن ليس هناك اي تقدم يذكر شكرا جزيلا لك
من دنيتك المراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات